now it's your turn let's move on to
another more real-world example now this
right here is a groundbreaking new
application called Udacity retained
aside from a snazzy name it does have
some pretty good organization when you
look at the underlying code so let's do
just that we have an HTML file a CSS
file and a JavaScript file if you look
at the JavaScript file we see a pretty
similar organization in this app as we
saw in our pizza application now we just
spent some time going over the pizza
application together just a moment ago
so go ahead and clone this repo and get
it onto your local machine then take a
look at it and try to figure out roughly
how it's organized you will see some
similarities between the pizza app and
this app here now if you have a moment
of disorientation that's normal anytime
I look at someone else's code for the
first time it takes me a bit to get my
bearings so don't worry if it takes you
a few minutes to start understanding
things feel free to comment things out
and see what breaks add comments as you
figure out what things do and notice the
big picture does the model ever talk to
the view directly how about the view to
the model